Halloween 2018 has been a big hit with audiences
and critics alike, however, the movie almost
had a completely different ending and opening
scenes.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm revealing Halloween's
alternate ending and how the movie almost
changed the original film's finale!
Make sure you watch to the end to also find
out all the other deleted scenes you never
got to see!
If you're new here, I do regular deep dives
into your favourite flicks, so make sure you
subscribe and also leave a comment about the
movie for a chance to win one of these cool
merch packs.
Spoilers ahead for Halloween, so take care
if you haven't seen the movie yet.
The end of Halloween 2018 saw Laurie and the
Strode women trap Michael Myers in the basement
and burn the house down, leaving us with the
question of whether Michael survived.
Originally though, the final confrontation
went down very differently but after it seems
test audiences reacted negatively, it was
completely reshot.
In the alternate ending, Laurie ends up facing
off against Michael outside her house, rather
than inside the house as happens in the final
film.
The deleted ending has Laurie trying to shoot
her tormentor but missing and then she finds
she's run out of bullets.
Michael has a kitchen knife, so Laurie pulls
out her hunting knife and charges at him.
She slices him in the arm in a reverse of
what he did to her in the 1978 movie, but
Michael plunges his own knife into Laurie's
chest.
But just as he's about to kill Laurie off
with a final blow, her daughter Karen emerges
from the house and shoots Michael in the shoulder
with a crossbow.
Michael drops his knife which Allyson picks
up and the three women stagger away from the
house.
Michael meanwhile is injured from the crossbow
arrow which has penetrated all the way through
his shoulder and he stumbles off into the
nearby wood.
Laurie pleads with Karen and Allyson to kill
him, but her voice is too weak for them to
hear.
After the women drive off in the truck, the
movie ends with Michael wandering into a clearing
filled with the creepy-looking mannequins
that Laurie uses for target practice.
The script for this discarded ending then
states that Michael sits down by a tree and,
exhausted, "his breathing deepens [… it's]
possibly his last".
Much of this ending was actually filmed as
you can see various scenes in the trailers
and promo footage which never made it into
the final movie.
And I can certainly see why it didn't test
so well with audiences as, in a number of
ways, it's not as satisfying as the ending
we did get.
Firstly, by placing the ending outside, we
would have missed out on Michael pushing Laurie
off the balcony in a nice reverse of how he
fell off in the original movie.
Secondly, Laurie's achievement of finally
trapping Michael in the safe room would never
have happened, making her character arc not
as fulfilling.
And thirdly, in the final film, burning down
the house also gives her an additional sense
of resolution and closure.
And on top of that, the deleted ending makes
it more obvious that Michael is very likely
still alive, whereas in the final film, it's
left open in a more interesting way.
A few fans have said that even the ending
we did get felt a little abrupt, however,
this alternate ending sounds like it would
have been much shorter again and perhaps rather
anticlimactic.
A major change that the Halloween 2018 filmmakers
almost made to the franchise's mythos is that
they very nearly altered the ending of the
first movie.
Most shockingly, if the new filmmakers' had
gone ahead with their alternate ending to
the original 1978 movie, we would have seen
Dr Loomis killed on screen!
Fortunately, John Carpenter advised director
David Gordon Green not to do that as, in his
opinion, it would have really annoyed the
film's fans.
Green had thought he needed to go back 40
years in his new film to remind people about
the ending to the first movie in case they'd
not seen it in a long time or were new to
the franchise.
And he planned to use his art director as
a body double for Donald Pleasence's Dr Loomis
because apparently, for the kind of shot they
were planning, he would have looked exactly
like the long deceased actor.
As for young Laurie, she would have been recreated
using a blend of Jamie Lee Curtis and a young
actress with a similar build to a 19-year
old Curtis.
They also looked into digitally altering existing
footage from the original movie and I wonder
if they were thinking of doing something similar
to what Rogue One did with both Peter Cushing's
character and a young Princess Leia?
They were even going to cast one of the movie's
production assistants as a young Sheriff Hawkins
because he looked like a young Will Patton
who plays the present-day Hawkins!
And that would have been filmed as part of
a scene showing Michael being captured by
the police.
In the end, John Carpenter told them they
were making things way too complicated and
that the audience didn't need this extra scene
to get up to speed; so, instead there was
just a single line of exposition from Dr Sartain
to Laurie when he explains that Hawkins was
"the first responding deputy [to arrive] when
Michael was arrested in 1978".
Interestingly, there's a little remnant of
this discarded reshoot idea in the final film.
Look carefully at the room where Laurie and
Michael face off in the finale, and you'll
notice that it's a replica of the bedroom
from the end of the 1978 movie.
The filmmakers had that set built to use for
their initial idea to reshoot the original
film's climax; but when they decided against
that, they used the set anyway to keep down
the budget.
And there's several additional deleted scenes
that ended up cut for pacing purposes.
The first one comes just after Michael has
escaped from the prison bus.
We cut to a shot of Dana, the British podcaster,
taking a shower.
The bathroom door opens slowly and a masked
man pulls back the shower curtain.
This scene was deliberately designed as an
homage to Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho, which
starred Jamie Lee Curtis's real-life mother
Janet Leigh in the iconic scene.
The little twist though is that the masked
man isn’t actually Michael Myers, it's the
other podcaster Aaron playing a prank on Dana.
Aaron then takes the mask off, gives a line
about how wearing the mask or the legacy of
it inspires a certain tendency and then makes
out with Dana.
Little fun fact now: Green's scrapped tribute
to Psycho would have been doubly fitting as
not only did Hitchcock's style influence John
Carpenter's original Halloween, but also Dr
Samuel Loomis was named after a character
from Psycho.
Curiously, Jamie Lee Curtis's mother [and
star of Psycho] Janet Leigh has previously
appeared in the Halloween franchise, playing
a secretary to her real-life daughter's character
in H20.
In fact, that movie included a little easter
egg to Hitchcock's movie, with a shot of the
same car driven by Janet Leigh's character
in the 1960s classic.
Another kill that was cut for pacing issues
is where Allyson was jogging and saw a dead
dog strung upside down in a tree.
It's not clear whether Michael killing the
dog was actually filmed, however, I suspect
it would have probably happened off screen.
This moment would likely have been a little
hat-tip to the two dogs that Michael killed
in the 1978 film – the first of which was
never shown on screen; though we did partially
see the death of the second dog Lester which
belonged to the little girl Laurie's friend
Annie was babysitting.
By the way, if you'd like to find out how
Halloween's filmmakers created the incredibly
creepy kill shots we did see in the movie,
tap the card to watch The Secret Truth About
Halloween 2018 or click the link in the description
below or on the card at the end of this video.
Another deleted scene revealed in behind-the-scenes
footage shows Laurie coming to speak with
her daughter Karen at Haddonfield Harmony
Community Center.
It looks like this was probably an additional
scene to illuminate a little more about Karen's
character and maybe where she works.
So, would you have liked to have seen any
of these deleted scenes in the movie?
And did you like the ending we got in the
final film?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and remember to subscribe for a chance
to win one of these cool Halloween merch packs.
If you'd like to learn more about my theory
on the movie's finale plus what I think the
crazy twist with Dr Sartain really means,
tap left for my ending explained video or
tap right for 10 freaky facts about the making
of Halloween 2018.
And if you enjoyed this, I really appreciate
a thumbs-up and a share.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!